(bright music)
♪ Yeah okay its tea ♪
♪ With GaryVee ♪
♪ Sipping is the key ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting out all my shit for free ♪
♪ This is tea with Garyvee ♪
♪ Mic go make a flip ♪
♪ Take a risk ♪
- Morning.
Good, good morning 4:21.
A wonderful Tuesday in April
we are now fully in it.
And we are fully into Teatime
the tea is in the building.
And we are fully into
this quarantine and COVID
and things that nature and
I hope everybody's families
are super well, and doing
as best as they can.
And so yesterday was a
monster of an episode
and let's see if we
can get an hour's worth
of great stuff today.
So, first and foremost,
always, please take
a screenshot of this right now
and share it on your Twitter
and if you're watching on
Facebook, hit the Reshare button.
That would be amazing and appear
on YouTube, tweet out that,
and let's get some awareness going,
share with your Facebook group.
Let's have a great show Dustin thank you
for being on the ones and twos again.
And let's just get right into it.
- Awesome.
Heidi.
- Hey Gray.
Hi, good morning,
- Hi good morning good
- over there.
- Yes it is, how are things.
- It's okay, it's really weird.
I think I'm seeing
things right now because
of the whole quarantine thing.
But I know we don't have a lot of times,
so I just wanna get into
it, obviously been a big fan
of yours for years, and I know you work
with a lot of entrepreneurs you've mentor
consultant and give tough love to,
a lot of entrepreneurs, I
guess my question would be,
from your experience talking
to a lot of entrepreneurs
what do you think, if this
is valid as the one thing
that you notice is holding back
a lot of female entrepreneurs,
specifically as opposed
to just male entrepreneurs?
- The truth is, I don't see I interact
with obviously a lot of men and women
and income levels, races,
there's always nuances,
obviously, insecurity is always
and judgment is always
an incredible driver but
but plenty of white males
that grew up in America
have massive insecurities
because their moms
or dads implemented it.
I think that sure there's cymatics,
I hear I hear constantly the excuse of ,
Gary I have to look good to make a video
from more women then men say
they've got to look the part
or otherwise they won't
be respected you hear
certain things, but the truth
is, it's pretty universal,
it's, people want things
too fast they actually don't
love their business, they
love money from a business
to buy things they want, that
destroys entrepreneurs cause
there's because they're not
entrepreneurs they're in
it right now because it
became the thing no different
those people 20 years ago
would have been doctors
and lawyers and dentists
and architects, or whatever
the money, brought to
it, what has happened
with entrepreneurship over
the last half decade is,
, people think that's where the money is.
And so we have a lot
of people going into it
who don't love it, a phenomenon
that became obvious to me
and when I got into VaynerSports,
so many athletes actually
don't love, their sport.
It's the place where they
can make the most money
so I think it's I think it's insecurity,
or it's complete and utter
addiction to buying things
or having, and then it
leads to insecurity right
because being car, having a
nice clothes having a big house,
having that car that everybody
thinks is cool, or flexing
on a picture of the nice
vacation you're on, oftentimes is
just another indicator to insecurity,
that you need outside validation,
to, drive your happiness,
and you're not able
to deal with criticism.
And then, and then now
what you're gonna see is
a lot of entrepreneurs
really fail because they just
really didn't actually
know how to run a business,
it was really, , their their economics
were upside down, they didn't save
they didn't make assumptions.
They didn't strategize
and so that's something
to think about.
- And then my last question would be,
just segwaying off that is
talking about insecurity.
How I deal with a lot of
people and myself I suffer
from insecurity sometimes,
how do you when you're
faced with that I have a lot of clients
or colleagues that are
insecure and I can come across
as really strong.
How do you make sure that they understand,
, be aware of that and
don't get defensive but
that's my number one thing
just working with people
they get super defensive
and then he just--
- Its tact, it's why I
think I do what I do well
it's delivering, I think most people
that are candorous don't know
how to deliver it with sugar.
- Give some sugar.
- The reason this whole
works and this show works
and I work is cause I'm coming
from a place of compassion
and love and empathy and
legacy, which leads to sugar.
Most people when they give
radical candor or shoot it
straight are actually
coming from a selfish place,
they're giving radical
candor that they hope
they spend more money with them,
or they're coming from a selfish place.
So, so how do you make
people not be defensive ?
Come from a place of
love and selflessness,
humans are animals, they sense things.
A lot of people think
they can just be a bull
in a china shop.
And that may work for a
little while, but long term
that is not a sustainable model
and you will lose your audience.
- I've seen you do it many
times you just dive in,
but I can tell but you also tell them, ,
what would work and you
also give them action items
so I can, its...
- Thanks for being on.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care yourself bye-bye.
- Bye.
- Lets keep it going Dustin.
What's good bro?
You're on, there we go cool.
You're on now.
How are you?
- Good, you?
- I'm well.
- Yes so if you don't mind I'm
gonna go ahead and jump
right into what I want
to discuss with you today.
so I'm a sophomore in
high school, who I live
in West Houston and I've
always been interested in
the entrepreneurial scene
in what you've been able
to contribute to it.
starting small business has
always been something that's in
the back of my mind, but it's
never something acted upon.
But just recently with a
large amount of free time
I've been given due to this
coronavirus operate I decided
to take advantage of it I
decided to take your advice.
Stop saying no and stop saying yes.
just recently I created my
own power washing business.
Now the only precautions I've
taken so far to expand upon
the creation My business is
through the distribution of
flyers door to door throw my neighborhood,
and through word of mouth.
So my question for you
today, Mr. Vaynerchuk is how,
how do I turn a laptop or
printer and a serious amount
of work ethic into a
business for someone my age.
A business that I can
not only create money
but a large amount of knowledge from.
- So first, step one you
never call me Mr Vaynerchuk,
cause I completely shut down,
definitely call me Gary.
- I'm so sorry for that.
- I'm kidding Cole.
All right, so Cole listen,
I think a couple things.
So the reality is you
have a huge advantage.
Number one by a country
mile for your business
and its a local business is Facebook ads.
I love the flyer hustle
, it's really ironic
one of my first hustles
for Wine Library was a flyer
to I barely used the computer
that my parents bought
me in late high school
at the time but one of the
things I did was print out
a 20% off coupon for Wine
Library and literally go to cars
and the short ball and
put other windows sales
so I love that hustle.
If Facebook existed I wouldn't have had
to do that and that's what
I actually want you to do.
I want you to really
focus on, on Facebook ads,
you can run them on a,
what a five mile radius,
, three mile radius.
And the key to Facebook ads,
is your gonna go with people
that live in your area, people
that are of a certain income
or some other target that
lets you go to people
that could afford, what
you're trying to sell.
And then the real key is you
need to make 25 to 50 different
pictures and videos and
find which one leads
to the most phone calls or
emails, and then cut out
the 22 that don't do well and keep running
the three that do well.
But Facebook ads Cole will
completely dominate for you.
, every local service business
if you're watching right
now in your landscaper.
If you wanna go to people's snow shoveler,
anything that's super local
pizza shop, a restaurant,
Facebook ads are by far
the best play to go.
It will explode, I predict,
A you have to have the $500
to be able to run the
ads, do you right now?
- Right now I have about 300 to work with.
- Awesome so you need
to take your Kansas City Royals shirt,
take it off your back, put it on Etsy
and sell it for 19 bucks,
you can literally go
in your room right now.
I'm being dead serious by the way.
You need to go in your
attic garage basement
or your room, whatever you have,
you need to sell everything
you own that you don't anymore.
And then you need to figure out if anybody
in your family is willing to give up
other things that they don't use anymore.
And you need to go ham on
Facebook marketplace Craigslist,
eBay, offer up--- all that
you need to convert that into $1,000,
and then you need to
run these Facebook ads
and I have a feeling your
business will have a real shot.
- All right, well thank you so much.
- Do you have stuff to sell?
- Yes I do, I--
- A ton, I'm telling you right
now Cole the number one thing
that I know is every fucking
person that's watching
this show right now.
92% have $1,000 laying
around their house, 1000,
people come from low,
even people with luck
this is a capitalist country, even people
that are bracketed a lower
income they buy shit.
You should have seen what
happened this week on e commerce.
Everybody got their stimulus
check of 1200 bucks,
they fucking wasted that shit.
This is a capitalistic buy-shit country
so almost everybody
watching almost everybody.
Obviously there's some homeless
services, real poverty line.
Obviously there's some frugal smart people
that have a budget but the far
majority of people right now
in their closet, basement,
living room, have ungodly amounts
of shit that they don't use
anymore that they don't care
about, and if they convert that
to flipping, A you'll learn
how to market on eBay Facebook
marketplace and Craigslist,
which will then help you
market your power wash company.
And you're gonna have 300
you're gonna have $987
instead of 300 bucks.
And you're gonna waste
your first hundred $200
on Facebook so you don't know
what the fuck you're doing.
And that's what we need.
Got it?
- Yep, sounds good, thank you so much.
- Good luck.
All right, here we go.
Let's go.
Katie, how are you?
- What's up, Gary.
- I love your shirt.
- I wore it for you.
I knew you'd it.
- I do love it.
- How are you?
- I'm well.
What can I help you with.
- I have a question for you.
It's really about, , I'm
thinking about passion
and I'm thinking about
how passion is often our.
I feel a sign of passion is
when you see the whole world
through that thing that you're
doing you can understand
people you understand
the world through that
and so you talk about
your love of the game.
And I wanna know what that
really is for you I want
to go, I want you to
go underneath that what
what is the game for you, actually and--
- Can you give me one second?
I'll be right back.
(slurping)
- I'll help reduce the awkwardness
by saying nothing important.
- I'm just stick to my seat.
- All right, sorry about
that I had to get my mom
set up properly.
She was trying to figure out how--
- Oh that's good.
to listen and watch.
Alright, what is the game
for me? I apologize--
- What does that actually mean?
You're clearly--
- I genuinely what I do,
the game for me is ...
I'd rather be building businesses,
I'd rather be doing this right now
than something else,
it's, it's, it's almost
this crazy liberating thing where it's ,
what if you could just
do whatever you wanted,
Katie, , , what would you do,
and I don't I think most people put work
into this place of ,
this is a requirement
to do what I wanna do. .
And for me, it's just what
I've always wanted to do.
It's why I struggled so much
in school all I would do
is daydream about starting a business
or I'm talking about third
grade fourth grade fifth grade ,
I can't wait to get hold into
this idea or I can't wait
to tell Robbie and Marissa,
we're gonna do this,
when when baseball cards hit me,
that was game over.
Then it was so much to
learn, and memorize them.
And then wine it's just
always the interest, .
- So, so for you, it's,
it's just about present,
it's about enjoying yourself
in every moment, or?
- I every part of it,
, it's kind of when I see those athletes,
that's why I associated with
recipes Kobe Bryant's so much,
I genuinely could see
that he loved practice,
and rehabbing injuries
as much as he did scoring
82 points in the game.
I understand that, i
enjoy last night, 9:40pm,
being in a meeting, trying to find costs
to save jobs at VaynerMedia.
which is a devastating you're
literally talking about
we have to do this or
Susie Maguire might have
to be let go,--
and I know her mom's got cancer.
I know that and so
devastating difficulties
of being an executive and
leader during these times,
yet I love that challenge,
even though that's not fun.
It's much more fun when
the world is not melting,
when you aren't dealing
with liquidity issues
in the global economy,
when you don't have to make
those decisions which were fun, ,
but at the same token, approach
challenge I do enjoy that.
Just it's not fun rehabbing a broken arm,
but if you love it if you
it actually love all of it,
all of it.
And to me, the stress
and the accolades being
on the front page of a Ink Magazine,
or being in a meeting last night at 9:40,
14 hours into your day,
making tough decisions leading
a group of other leaders,
which probably wanna be off the Zoom,
cause its 9:40 already,
who are finding themselves working more,
not less than one this
time, no that's real shit.
And so to me that's loving my game.
People love entrepreneurship
when it's convenient.
People love being a
lawyer when they litigate
but not when they, ,
are behind the scenes,
and when you're that you're
vulnerable because then you're
not completely fully succumbed
to that love that process
that's so that's what when
I talk about loving my
game every part of it, not
just the parts that are
convenient, but not just
the parts that bring me
what I want.
The far majority of entrepreneurs
that position themselves right now
cause I've watched my whole life they love
what entrepreneurship
does for their clout,
for their credit, for
the potential of the boat
they can buy with it.
They don't love it.
- So in those moments I
feel people are becoming
entrepreneurs because they have a thing
that they wanna do, but--
- You could do a thing without having all
the baggage that comes
with being an entrepreneur.
Or it can be a side hustle
or it can be a nonprofit,
or even number two to somebody
who's already doing it in
a way that you admire and is incredible.
Right, or, or you could have
the humility to do it exactly
how you want it's your thing.
But you just might make 49,000 a year.
Some of the most successful
entrepreneurs I know
make 49,000 a year.
It's because they love honey.
They have four bee things in the backyard,
they hand package it.
They sell it for 71,000 a
year with a ton of profit so
they make 49,000, and
they're happy as fuck.
They're just not fucking living
their life with an Escalade
and biggest nights and private
jets and, and that I admire
way more than the people that
are making pretend they're
living that life.
You see where I'm going?
- Mm-hmm.
- When people Oprah Gary I have
to see my vision through, I'm amazing.
You could be an entrepreneur
see your vision through.
But let's talk about the
financial part, because you're
overlaying that you need
to also be a millionaire
and your passion and your
idea, and your ability is your
ability as an artist and a
thinker is high, but as a
business operator to make a
million dollars with it because
e guess what Katie, if I
started a fucking honey company,
it would do $10 million.
Because I have the
operations, and marketing
and all these all the
variables that lead to that.
I just want people to be
happy making 49,000 with
their passion and loving all
the process, because I can tell
you one thing I wouldn't love,
I wouldn't love shoring up the honey.
- That's kind of my question--
- But I can make 10 million
and afford to pay somebody
to do it.
I did my own social media,
all you fuckers that are , " Oh you've got
"a team, fuck you," I
did my own social media
for eight years without
anybody on my team.
Cause I loved it, which
made me the best at it,
which then let me be able
to afford to hire it,
which then be able enabled
me to be able to judge
if somebody was good at it
cause I fucking did it first.
- So that's where the
patience kind of seems
to come in right?
- Mm-hmm.
- You have to make the
jump to make the jump,
to make the jump.
- That's why patience is so huge,
because everybody was struggling with
what I'm just talking about right now.
If they thought about 15 year terms,
instead of 15 week terms, they
would get excited about doing
it, it would also put pressure on you
to say do you actually love this,
or you're trying to make a quick buck.
Awesome, thank you.
- Awesome, thanks Gary.
- Take care.
All right, let me say
hello to some people.
I fucking love this guy,
I love you too Colton.
Crystal Maze we are hoping.
Mark Trabin, it is an show.
Big shout out to everybody on YouTube.
Those comments flying in heavy.
Let's keep it going.
Gary.
- Gary, can you hear me?
- I can Jeffrey.
- Well, first of all,
virtual knuckle bp video,
he's doing a great job.
Thank you very much appreciate that.
My question is about
strategy and at the end
of the question I've got
two things I wanna give you
and one thing I wanna ask in return.
So, so first of all strategy.
I've been independent guy.
I'm 55 years old, career working
for technology companies,
five years ago the company
was sold I was left holding
a big bag of zero.
And so I went out on my own.
And I been doing okay, in
five years built the business
up close six figures, me and a
few contractors when I needed
them so it's been doing really well now,
COVID has happened to all of us.
Businesses has fallen at 60%,
I'm sure you can live with that.
But it's given me.
I survived, 2000, 2001,
when it was the dot.com
bubble burst, followed by 911
which totally took me out,
totally wasted me to ashes.
Right, so, me and my beautiful
wife we were prepared
for this, , because we
were always prepared
for this right so I'm in a good spot.
So that said--
- Jeffrey apologies for
interrupting it's probably
the thing I'm most excited
about of all the horrible things
with this situation.
The thing that I'm most excited about is
in 2000 and 2001, and
I and I lived through
that era as well,
with a double punch of the .com
burst in April and then 911.
You learnt and so you
changed our behavior,
we're gonna have an enormous group
of under 30 year olds that just learned
that their influence or
business or this business
or that business so that is
something I'm glad you brought
that up and that's something
I definitely think is gonna
be a help, even though they
don't know it yet because
it hurts to start over, but keep going.
- We'll to add on that all the people
listening, this is gonna
happen and something is going
to happen again in your
lifetime so you'll learn learn
the lesson--
- multiple times.
- and move on.
So, I'm gonna move here
because I got the long guys
who are very inconvenient.
- No worries.
So strategically what I
do is I've taken pause
and I'm looking back at my
the work I've been doing.
And it will surprise you
this but I found that 20%
of the work that I was
doing was my high paying
super interesting work that
was just thrilling and used
every bit of what is me.
- That's awesome.
- 80% of it was low paying
customers were kind of difficult
to work with.
And it was wrote and it got boring.
So what I'm talking
about doing for myself.
Let me give an example that
because when you start you
take every job when you're
starting your business,
you say no to nothing.
- Of course, I say yes
to everything, and then
you start to weed off.
How you read off is a
really interesting strategy,
do you command, line in the
sand have a substantial growth
in revenue.
I always I always say, say
yes to everything upfront,
and then when you're at
the maturity to say no,
before you say no, you make an
offer that they probably have
to refuse by saying,
"Hey it's been very nice,
"our contract's up, I need
double to keep going,"
and what what people will
find is that half, not half 10
to 15% will actually double
up, which is a nice thing.
- One thing I found out the one customer
this totally surprised me.
My biggest surprise in year number three
I fired my first customer.
I said, it's the wrong fit,
I honestly I'm not right for
you and I've never thought
I would ever do that.
My point being is this,
is that I wanted to,
I wanna have more of that 20% of the work
and less of the 80% of that
work from from the past life.
And so right now I'm down 60% or more.
I can't hurt my business I'm saying?
what I've been thinking is
using this as the opportunity
to reposition my brand, and not eliminate
the easier smaller lower paying work,
but I wanna emphasize and explode--
- You got it Jeffrey, your
maturity and the skills
and learnings are there.
You're not gonna fire them
you're just gonna spend 100%
of your time getting more of that 20%
and over time that amortizes out.
And then, then you'll have
the leverage to cut that off.
That's exactly right.
- Perfect.
I've got two things for you
the two things I have for you.
First is the, The All-In challenge.
They won't let me buy,
I live in Puerto Rico,
and they have they have
their delivery settings set
so that they won't deliver
to Puerto Rico but--
- I think that's based on
the auction and, and
sweepstakes rules in America,
of what we can and can't take,
so let me look into that.
Or, you have to use a surrogate,
I've seen a lot of people do.
So thank you for bringing that up.
- I know the number five
is important to you.
- Yes, very important.
- Did that Roman numerals, the number five
is the letter V.
- I sure do, I also know
that my son's name is Andrew
with an X and my nickname for him is 15,
cause he has X-V so--
- Perfect, nice job.
Then if I could ask--
- Please.
- one more thing if you're
generous, one more thing,
if you would, I started to
rebrand myself I started
a podcast called the Jeff effect.
If you would just say,
in any way you want to,
this is GaryVee Welcome
to the Jeff effect.
- You got it.
Hey everybody its Gary
Vaynerchuk, and you're listening,
to the Jeff Effect.
- awesome i love that.
- You got it,
take care brother,
- thank you so much.
stay well, bye-bye.
- Cheers.
Let's keep it going.
I Jeff's fake jab, jab, right hook.
Lemme give you things that are just okay,
can I get in return
something that's monstrous,
I the hustle Jeff,
that's why I gave it to you.
let's keep it going.
- Hey Gary.
- Hey Adrian.
- good morning man.
I'm a big fan of our Mexico.
Nice meeting you.
- Nice to meet you.
- That Katie call hit me really hard.
It makes sense, about my question.
Yesterday you were talking
to a guy called Kevin,
He didn't want his son to choose a career
that he's not passionate about.
And my question is,
how do when to change careers?
Because, I might be--
- anytime you debate it.
You already know.
You already know the fact
that you asked me the question
I can tell you firmly that you should.
- The thing is that I wanna be 100% sure.
- You are 100% sure it's the
question you decided to ask me.
you're scared, you're worried
about the ramifications
financially, but you're 100% Sure.
- I know for a fact, what
I'm passionate about.
I know for a fact, what
is my purpose in life.
I know what I wanna do.
But the thing is, well, I chose--
- He's the good news.
Go ahead I'm sorry finish.
- No, I chose well, I'm a medical student.
I chose medicine.
Because it was a good thing.
- Your parents wanted you to
or you also are conservative
and thought it was the right thing to do.
- well, my parents obviously
the idea but I am very
passionate about health, but I
don't know if the medicine is
actually leading me to where I wanna be.
- Are you still a medical
student, or you practicing?
- Yes, I'm a medical student currently.
- Are you in debt or your
parents paying for the school
or how does Mexico work?
- They're actually very supportive parents
they have always paid for my tuition,
my rent, my food, everything.
- Do you feel guilt bailing now?
- I don't wanna disappoint them.
- Of course.
Well, what about you telling
them that you'll pay them back
after you make it in 13 years?
- That's kind of the idea.
- I think that's huge accountability.
And I think that's a
really interesting thing
and by the way, based on
your parents already being
in a place where they've done based vibes,
I almost think there's a 80%
chance they won't take it
When that time comes.
And there's probably 100%
chance that you'll wanna give
it to them when that time comes.
Now the question is, do you
actually believe in yourself?
- I do believe in myself I actually--
- Then I have your answer,
you should change courses now,
you should count up how much you owe,
in what they pay for,
and you should tell them
that one day you'll pay them back.
And you'll be happy.
And then you'll be a man
standing on your own two feet
and you'll be pumped.
- I was hoping, before the show
that he will say that so...
- Then we're in a god spot, we won.
- I always hear your shows
and obviously you'll always
talk about passion and that Katie call
actually hit me right...
- Makes me happy but listen,
have passion, legacy,
destiny it all comes down to one thing.
Life is actually remarkably
simple, good, bad,
light, dark, positive, negative.
Everybody makes everything so complicated.
Perfection, 100% sure,
other people's opinions,
resentment, dwelling, thinking they can go
into a time machine and fix something.
It is only going forward.
It is only positivity, it is only light,
it is only make yourself happy.
You going now changing
course and paying them back,
even the offer of you
paying it back is something
your parents would be so proud of.
However that conversation
works out, whether you do
or you don't, you're gonna
be (sighs) and on your way.
The greatest strength is to
change your mind, my friend.
- How?
You have no (mumbles).
- In what sense?
- It takes courage to change your mind.
You have new data to change your mind,
you were a fucking child, when you decided
to go into medicine.
You now have the understanding
that you don't it as much.
changing your mind is the most
powerful thing in the world
and people are petrified of
it, because they're worried
about the judgment because
of the story that they've
created for their circle
that now they're changing it
cause they talked a big
game, or people will think
I wasn't capable.
I quit on shit, all the time that I'm more
than capable of doing.
I just don't wanna do it.
- That's totally the thing.
I truly know I can manage
them everything but...
- Brother, I truly know
that I probably could
have gotten decent grades,
I just didn't wanna.
- That's actually
happening to me right now ,
I should be studying for finals but I'm
actually watching every video of yours--
- Cause you don't wanna do it.
And I promise you if you were working
on your healthy food brand.
If you were working on
your fitness programme
that you were gonna sell
you would be watching me
for tactics, not for escapism.
- You are a wizard man.
- I'm trying, appreciate you bro.
Talk to you soon.
- Thank you, bye, thank you.
- Feeling it man, this
fucking show Dustin!
- Yes sir.
- We're gonna have to
figure out how to continue
the show post-COVID right?
- I have been thinking about it.
- This is the best content
I've ever put out right?
- for sure.
- why am I be TV iconic rarely
worked, or , asked to be show
pretty epic was the transition
to this new version of me
daily DailyVee was such
an incredible new concept,
it created the D ROC
phenomenon, straight up,
Nobody was following
anybody with camera before.
But this...
- It's truly helping people.
- That's such a good point.
I feel before I was at a nine.
And I feel this is a 10, but
what I'm worried about is
I'm gonna have to really
work on myself to feel safe.
Because what's happening
here it's more about me,
I don't feel anxious about the time frame.
Whereas, when I do Ask
GaryVee or the podcast,
I know they have to be
out I have to be out,
maybe it is the morning.
what's funny?
how I always said we
have to do these things
at night because then I
go home on the back end?
- Mm-hmm.
- I almost wonder if the morning's better
because I know subconsciously
I have my whole day to catch
up on anything that got fucked up.
That just hit me.
- If that makes sense to
you then it makes sense.
- Because I could start
at least a $50 million
director consumer tea business
on the back of this too.
Speaking of which, Wine
Text , get in there Dustin,
winetext.com.
It is time for my daily commercial
for my dad's winetext.com.
Two days ago, a lot of people signed up.
Last time we did this, not as
many so I'm very disappointed,
so I'm gonna go hard because
I don't want Brandon,
to make fun of me that
nobody signed up from Tea.
This is very simple, if you buy wine.
If you buy wine at all,
more than two times a month,
simple this is the simple thing.
If you buy wine, if you
drink a bottle of wine,
more than two times a month,
please go sign up to wine text right now,
it is literally the single best service
in the industry right now.
It takes two minutes to sign
up, two seconds to order.
You literally get a text
every day with a deal,
today's this insane $25 in Zinfandel,
15,16 bucks, there was an $80...
yesterday was a $43 cab that
we sold for $19 and change,
flew out in 27 minutes.
It is literally the best.
Please unsubscribe from
your bullshit wine clubs,
please stop buying from
other services do the emails,
stop going to your local
stores or supermarkets,
no Costco or Trader Joe's.--
If I brought you any value,
it would mean the world to me,
if you signed up for wine text.com.
If you just signed up for wine text.com,
please leave a comment in here.
Yes, Robin, the wines do sell out fast.
And if you're not a wine drinker,
just take a one second
pause and take winwtext.com,
and post in your Facebook post especially
or Twitter it would mean a lot to me.
Mindy there is free shipping
on 12 bottle orders,
but it's $6 flat.
So if you order six bottles
it's $1, a bottle shipping
or if you order three bottles
just $2 a bottle shipping
and when you're having the
savings that we're putting
and these are ridiculous
deals, we've got five full time
people just buying, trying
to get the best deals,
it is remarkable.
It is the best.
There's a bunch of deals a
day, email services and apps
and email newsletters from good
wine stores I'm telling you
this is 100 times better.
Please add it to your
repertoire, it would mean
the absolute world to me.
Thank you Michelle for signing up.
Thank you Ross for...
it is ridiculous wine, when it's been huge
means a lot to me so.
Alright, let's keep going.
Eli not a lot of cultural wines,
maybe two three times a year.
Cole okay.
- This crazy you Warren
Buffet and my dad are
my go to guys right here.
- I appreciate that,
that's good company.
- I'll have to get my dad
to sign up for you cause
he drinks two glasses
of wine every night.
- Cole I want your
fucking dad on Wine Text
that is a huge requirement.
- I'll get along for you don't worry.
- What state do you live in?
- I'm on Long Island so New York.
- Beautiful, he's in.
Tell him he's getting
ripped off and he needs
to be on Wine Text.
Go ahead.
- I got you.
- I trust you.
- I have a lot of passions
and strong interests.
I've always loved investing
in stocks, cryptocurrency.
Recently, I just got my drone
license, I was gonna work
this summer for my Bartender
view, started a real estate,
fly drones around and
you just take pictures
of the houses and stuff.
I just signed up for a
drop-shipping Shopify course,
which to be honest I've
learned more from that
than full year of college this year.
I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing.
- Oh its a bad thing brother.
- Its bad thing,
- Its a very bad thing
because you or your parents
or the state paid for
that college education.
It's a bad thing.
Education is the greatest thing on earth,
being educated, being more
woke up, being more thoughtful,
spiritually, informationally,
it's the greatest
thing on earth.
- It was 300 bucks and I've learned
more way more from that
than a year of college but--
- but the way we currently
package education in America
and how we charge, and
how we don't let people...
We literally let people run
scams and file bankruptcy
and get it off the debt.
And when we don't let people
get their college tuition
off their debt on
bankruptcy, it is the literal
fucking racket.
Now for 23 to 37% of people
today in the medical field legal
it's still a complete
requirement that piece of paper,
but fuck me.
It's broken bro.
- It definitely is then, I
started off with Tick Tok
I'm doing this Chinese
yo yo thing which I've
never seen.
No one's doing that in Tik Tok obviously.
- You're a creative kid, I it.
Keep going, I can answer for you.
- So my question is just I
feel I'm kind of all over
the map with everything should
I double down on one thing
and get rid of something else?
- No, I'm a big fan let me
rephrase everyone's different
but based on what I'm hearing,
no, I'll tell you why.
It's a huge advantage at
this young of an age to taste
a lot of things.
- Keep going bro, I still do it.
I have empathy, VaynerX
is now crazy it's not
just VaynerMedia, it's the Sasha
Group for small businesses,
it's the Gallery Media
Group, One37pm and PureWow,
for publishing there's VaynerSpeaking,
I've a speaking bureau.
We have Tracer a business
intelligence data, media,
analyzation SAS business, we have
something we're announcing next week
that's very close to what you're talking
about with drop shipping.
So, it's something that I,
I love doing all these different things.
Some people are just that
creative but operational
some people have a lot of things,
and don't operate any of them.
Right, so there's this
great saying in the NFL,
" If you have two
quarterbacks you have none."
I think about that a business.
I'm able to focus on one
core thing VaynerMedia,
which allows me to have the GaryVee brand.
It allows me to have all
the VaynerX companies,
it allows me to have Empathy,
it allows me to help
my dad with Wine Text,
it allows me to staff
50 people against the
All-In Challenge.
By the way have you seen
the Al-In Challenge yet?
- Yes, it's amazing, you came
up with that all by yourself?
- No, actually Michael Rubin,
the founder of Fanatics
which is an incredible e-commerce
and he's amazing entrepreneur
he came up with the idea,
he brought in his friend
Allen Tish to do with him
a couple days later they are .
"Fuck we need to explode
this, lets bring in Gary,"
but we do a lot of marketing
and I have done a lot
of the auctions for him.
- Its such a good idea
(mumbles) kind of way
to raise money otherwise.
- Dude the raffle
tickets are 10 bucks some
of that stuff you need to put 40 bucks
into to try win a ticket.
Anyway, I think you keep tasting
based on what I'm hearing.
- All right, so just--
- You wanna honestly know
about your older brother
I would actually say to
you. "Yo bro, do three or
"more things."
- I'm just stuck in my house,
i can't do anything so there's
nothing better to do.
- Nothing better.
- Take the Shopify
courses and learn stuff.
- Learn how to do content on LinkedIn.
It's a little fun fact play with that.
Get into that, all right
bro talk to you soon.
Oh go ahead.
- My other thing was you always
talk about loving the game
which I definitely do I love doing stuff,
but I also love money too.
Not to spend money, I
just love saving money.
- That's good, man.
Cole you're going be
successful, it is very likely.
That if you love the
idea of amassing money
and you love being creative and the grind.
You've been gifted with
some real DNA, that's good.
There's nothing wrong with
amassing and saving money
using money to buy things to hide behind
your actual unhappiness,
that's what I'm concerned.
You saving money, people
buying Lamborghini
cause they actually know what that is
and they love that feeling
and they're not using it
to front and they can afford it.
The greatest thing in the
world, somebody's buying
a Lamborghini on credit
they can't afford, because
they wanna get the girl and
they think they need that,
or they got picked on or they
actually don't themselves
because their parents did a bad job.
That's what I'm trying to fight against.
- Gotcha.
- Got it.
- The last thing, you don't
have to watch it but I made,
there's a new trend on take stock,
whatever's how's my forum
or whatever at the end
where you're supposed to target a specific
group of people or person
So I'm made one about you.
- I love it
Hit up Dustin.
- If you wanna watch it or anything.
- What's your what's
your ticktock account?
- It's Cole and then Cornell
no spaces, just spelling
C-O-L-E Cornell, the college.
- That's the other thing, man
You have an epic name.
You're set Cole.
Cole Cornell is a proper
fucking name for success.
- Thank you.
- Cole focus on happiness,
all the other shit
you were gifted I'm telling you.
- Alright, awesome
- Just focus on happiness, bro.
Stay quiet in your head,
that's how it gets good.
- Thank you so much.
- All right brother.
Talk to you soon.
- This was awesome.
- You got to Cole.
Good show so far.
Hi Linda.
- Hi Gary.
Oh my gosh.
I just listening to you this morning.
- Thank you
On and my leg.
- Oh yes.
- I heard about you.
Yeah, I just, I got up this morning,
I know it's going to be on, I
supposed to be on yesterday.
You, I'm , all right.
- How did you that episode?
- I haven't listened to all of it.
I'm about 40 minutes in and its amazing.
Just thank you
I'm just so honored
I'm getting all emotional.
But the reason I called for
one is just one to thank you
for everything you're doing.
Second you had Dr. Mark
Hyman on your show while ago
and I was just , oh my gosh, that's me.
I'm the female version of him just ,
trying to tell people you gotta take care
of your health man.
That's everything because without this
it's just you can't do anything in life.
And right now I feel it's the perfect time
that my business should be thriving.
I love what I do,
I've gone out and again, the
speaking thing, I worked for
a nutrition company actually
going out, speaking,
getting free seminars.
I do all that.
I do e-Books, I have YouTube
videos telling people
how to do things.
I'm doing the jab, jab and
just giving, giving, giving,
I'm , why am I not thriving?
- Thriving financially?
- Yeah.
- Are you asking for money?
- Oh yeah.
I have a practice and,
right now I've been doing
a lot of video chats.
- Do you think you're good at
the ask or does it come easier
for you to do the give?
- It doesn't come easy.
- Yeah
Listen, it's super funny.
Did you ever read my book
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook"?
- I haven't heard a lot about it.
- Dustin, as soon as it's
over, connect with Linda
and send her a copy.
Let's get my publisher
to send her a copy of
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook".
Awesome
So Linda, I'm going to send you a copy.
You're welcome
I want you to read it
It's funny when I wrote it
and the concept for everybody
who doesn't know, cause I
wrote it several years ago,
seven or eight years
ago now, I think it's,
give, give, give and then ask.
Too many times people at the
time on the internet were
just asking, everything
was sale, sell, sign up
for my course, sign up for my
Zoom, sign up for my lesson,
my coaching and I...
it was disgusting and
it was just not working
And I was , fuck, I got to help the world.
I'm going to tell them
how I'm doing it, which is
give, give, give and then ask.
So for example, you just saw
and you've been watching maybe
Tea I'm really asking people
to sign up for my dad's
Wine Tech service cause
I love my dad a lot
and it's really a good service
and I'm really happy about it.
It works for both ends.
anybody who buys wine
is going to save money
and get better wine and my
dad's going to be pumped.
You would be shocked Linda,
how many people are watching
right now buy wine all the time
and still have not signed up
and have gotten ungodly amounts
of value for me right now.
Right now they're watching and
literally that just hit them
right in her chest cause fuck, really?
I really didn't take the two
minutes to sign up and do this.
Forget that's true.
So it, you understand it's not
take when you give, it's ask.
Couple things, when I wrote
it, I thought I was doing it
for all the people that were
just spamming all the time.
What I realized when I got
the feedback was the people
that got the most out of it were you,
the people that weren't good at asking.
Because when they asked,
they were half pregnant,
they weren't with conviction,
they weren't straight
and they weren't , it was just convoluted
cause it didn't come easy to them.
- I get that too because
it's , I feel at 12,
so my husband yesterday,
I feel I'm the GaryVee
when it comes to health and wellness,
because it's just if somebody
comes in and they have
an issue, I'll look at their blood work.
They've been to all these doctors
and it's bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
I figure things out, I'm
this is what we're gonna do.
And everything i do is
natural and drug less show.
It's just , I feel , man,
I am so good at this,
I should have tons of...
How do you ask?
Do you have a big email list?
You have a big social following?
- Not really, maybe 1500 I said, I do,
I have videos that, I have maybe--
- How do you ask?
On a post?
how do you go in for the ask?
How do you do it?
- No, usually I do free,
I give away free e-books
but I also have on my website
a free 15-minute phone consult just
to see if I can help them.
- And how does that work?
Do you get a lot of 15s?
- Yes and no, it maybe 90% are conversion,
but lately I haven't and
usually those that do,
because everything is consi--
- How many people follow you on Instagram?
- Probably about 500.
I don't have a lot of followers.
- How many emails do you have?
- Probably about 1500 on my list.
- You should send an email
today and say, "I would all
"of you to follow me on Instagram.
"I'm gonna start doing a
lot of Instagram lives,
"here's a link to my Instagram."
I wanna take some of those
1500 and add another 87 to 219
to your Instagram list.
Then I want you to do a
post on your Instagram
that is literally black and
white with your phone number
and if you have to get
a Google phone number,
do what a Google voice number is?
Because you may not want to
give you way your actual number,
but what I want you to do, how
sometimes Dustin throw it up
on the bottom right now, how
I put out my phone number,
I want you to post out on
your Instagram just a black
and white with a phone number.
Google how to get a Google voice number.
Get a Google voice number so
you don't give everybody in
the world your number.
But I want you to post and
say, I'm giving away 15,
literally the post is
your phone number and say,
"Please call to get a 15-minute
consultation with me."
You need to become a better...
Linda the reason you're not succeeding is
cause you're not a good sales person.
- I now that.
- I know that too.
And that's okay.
By the way, good news,
just I wasn't eating well
and working out and that's
why I wasn't in the best shape
that I could be, and it came
super not natural to me.
Me getting better with my
health is probably the biggest
accomplishment I've ever done because it's
the one accomplishment
I've done that desperately
did not come natural to me.
It also gave me the
energy to give advice even
more because now I saw
that it wasn't just DNA.
You need to become a
way better salesperson.
- I think what my challenge
with that is because I've been
to so many seminars where
they just sell from the stage
and they have multiple speakers.
- That's bullshit, but guess what?
That's bullshit and I call
that shit out all the time.
Guess what?
I've seen those two...
I've been at some of those
conferences and gone in there
and fucking shit on
everybody that was there.
Don't do that.
That's not selling.
Selling is what I do.
Believing in what you're selling
and doing it in a nice way
where you just ask, not
trick them with a funnel.
Don't manipulate, sell.
Those are two very different things.
- What is your definition
of what that to me?
No selling is great
when you believe in it.
I'm being serious not
to beat a dead horse,
I genuinely believe right this
second that anybody who buys
wine in America is better
off signing up for Wine Texts
than buying anywhere else
because I know the business
so well.
I know that text message
buying is the best.
You get a text, you hit three, enter
and it comes to your house.
It makes Amazon feel difficult.
I also know that every wine
that we text out is by far
the best price on that wine
that has ever been sold at,
and it's extremely high quality
and it's the type of wines
that will expand people's pallets.
The reason I'm up here
pushing it so often is 90%
cause I love my dad blindly, but 10%
because I just know it's awesome.
The reason I think
everybody should hire Sasha,
the Sasha Group is cause
there's a lot of people watching
right now that really
could use it and it would
be way better than the agency
or the internal team they have.
The reason I don't push
that as often is because
that's very close to Gary marketing man.
And I don't want to kind
of monetize my audience
whereas the wine thing has
nothing to do with anything
other than don't go to
Trader Joe's or Publix
or Total Wine or BevMo!
and buy dumb shit.
If you actually believe
the part you said up front,
that you're the best at it,
then you're good at it.
- I'm damn good.
- Well then you need to
get rid of that insecurity
that you co...
You're worried about how you
come off because you watched
other people come off sleazy.
So don't be fucking sleazy.
And as a matter of fact,
you're using a lot of
their sleazy tactics, a
free e-book, a consultation
that's meant to be a funnel.
How about a piece of content
that just straight forward
that says, you should fucking use me.
I'm good at what I do.
I'm $400 an hour.
I'm being serious.
By the way, on the record,
I don't hate a free e-book
and consultation, but we can both agree
that if you're worried about
the people that are on stage
that are sleazy, those are those tactics.
So you've already succumbed to the tactic.
- Can you hear me?
- I can hear you perfectly.
Can you hear me?
I wanna first make sure that
you're actually confident
in what you're selling, I
mean it, in the subconscious.
And then if that's not a
problem, which I actually don't
think it is with you
based on listening to you,
I just think you need to do that
or and stick with me here,
find a way to afford somebody
to be the sales person for you.
That's great.
There's an unbelievable amount
of people watching right now,
everybody, this is her Instagram.
If you're a 15-year old, 19-year
old that you think you're
great at sales and you think
you can spend the month
really getting to know her
and then be a sales person
for her and take a 20%
commission of every consultation
she gets, you'll make a ton of money,
she'll make a ton of money
and two people will be happy.
- Wow
I would love that.
One other quick question,
because I've heard you say this,
I really wanna do a lot in my community.
I've only been here for about five years
and I was thinking of doing a podcast just
for the community.
- Real quick,
yes you should do that, yes.
Karma, I'm reading a lot of the comments.
You're gonna get hit
up by a lot of people.
I see a lot of people
saying, I can help Linda,
on the record I don't want
anybody talking to her
that can help her by selling
your $400 sales course.
You can only help her
have one of two ways,
free advice cause you're a good human
or you'll be compensated as a sales person
for her purely on commission.
Do not hit her up if you can help her
by selling your $1,500 sales course.
Sorry Linda just had to do that PSA.
- Thank you.
- You are loaded with
a doubt around sales.
And by the way, I'm loaded
with doubt around logistics.
I do not trust myself to book my calendar
or make sure I'm going on the right plane
or make sure I'm in the right place,
which is why I have admins.
At first I didn't and for
years and years of my career
have admins or an admin.
So it took me a long time
to be able to afford it
Luckily in sales, I'm telling
you right now, you're gonna
hang up here and you have to start crying
cause you're gonna have
55 DMS on your Instagram.
Do use your Instagram enough to know where
to see your direct messages?
- Yes I do.
- And I promise you of those
55, six of them are gonna
say, I'm willing to sell your
program just on commission,
and one of those six is
the right human for you
and you're both going
to make a lot of money.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome
- Appreciate it.
And I just, I did buy tickets
for the All-In Challenge.
- Oh, i love that.
Thank you for supporting it.
- I don't play fine but if I did,
but I am sharing everything.
- Just share your Facebook it
would mean the world to me.
It is a resource, awesome, thank you.
- Greatly appreciate it.
Thank you
- Bye bye.
- All right, we've got five minutes.
Let me see how hardcore my 11 is.
Alright, let's sneak one more in.
- Oh my God.
- Alex what's good?
- Its good man.
Oh my God, I can't believe
I'm here with you right now.
- We are here bro, where'er you from?
- I'm from California
West Coast represent.
- I love it.
- I couldn't sleep today,
this morning I woke up
at 3:00 AM cause I was
just so nervous and anxious
and just gained to be here.
You're my lifesaver man.
- Thank you, bro.
- I'm trying really hard, not
to be emotional too, but ,
I ran away from home when I was 17
and I look up to people like
you and I'm here
- Thank you, proud of you.
living by myself.
Even though I'm not
making a lot of money...
- You're happy.
- Yeah, I'm happier, my money
shit but I love my passion,
I love dancing and yeah,
- You're winning
- I'm just living a happy life right now.
- That's right, you're winning.
And you can afford a
$35 bullshit Jordan hat,
so you living.
- I hate that man, but I respect
him, respect to the GOAT,
I know who he is and I know what he means.
Anyway
- Thank you.
- What can I do for you?
- Honestly, I'm just trying
to do my passion right now.
I've been documenting what you say,
document myself just put a
freestyle as on my Instagram,
my dance I kinda put stories
for a Final Fantasy Seven,
I'm just trying to figure
out how can I make myself,
really just give myself to
other people cause I've been
working so hard to to help myself be,
I've been selfish about
myself and not chasing money
or anything that and really not...
I just want to be able to inspire people.
You can be just happy at home.
- I hear so many people that
they want to inspire people,
inspiring people is
very easy now it's 2020.
You make videos, you put
them on Tik Tok, Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat and
you'll inspire someone.
Inspiring people is very different
than building an audience
that you can monetize so that
you can be self sustaining
for your life.
Inspiring people, you have a crazy story.
You ran away from home,
there's a lot underneath that.
You can inspire a ton of
people by telling real stories
and crying on YouTube and
Instagram and you'll fucking
do great stuff, I mean that
brother, you'll do great stuff.
Alex I think building a
life of sustainability
that makes you happy is a different story.
I love that you're testing out
Final Fantasy videos can make
are you good enough?
I love that.
I love that you're putting
out beats or hip hops
and things that nature.
It's so early and as long as
you're super tight with it,
afford the ability to do your passion.
You got a real shot.
- I think that's one of the
things I'm struggling with as
well is because I have
this vicious cycle about,
okay I hate working at a shitty job,
so I'm going to chase my passion.
I fucked myself over, excuse my language
because I don't have
the money to sustain--
- Alex, who're fucking with?
We're good with language bro.
Why not get a shitty job
that looks one of two ways
to let you do your passion.
Why not get a shitty job at
Game Stop so that you're still
in the culture of video games
that might lead to serendipity
that you might meet somebody
that comes in that pops off
for you or get a shitty job
at 7-Eleven where you can
be on your phone all day
while you're at the register
cause they're loose that
at this one location.
Shitty jobs are amazing
if you're strategic.
There's two shitty jobs
that everybody should get
when they need to.
The one that just lets you
work on your phone all day,
cashier, hostess, hosts, small
business that just doesn't
give a fuck as long as you do the thing.
A toll booth, security guard,
you see where I'm going?
Or shitty job within the
culture that you want.
I hear Final Fantasy, I'm ,
yo, go be an intern at EA.
Yo, go be an intern at Activision.
Yo, go work $11 an hour
at fucking Game Stop
because a fucking
YouTube influencer might
come in and become your boy
or your girl and fucking put you on.
Shitty jobs strategically
are the fucking game
and are about to become the game for
the 30 plus million Americans
that need a fucking job.
This is gonna be maybe
an important clip for me.
There's a shitty job strategy
that's going to really matter
and I just laid it out
there one of two ways
in the game that you want to be in.
So that 70% gums or so loose
that you can fucking build
your life here while you're
getting your nine bucks an hour.
Shitty job strategy bro.
Shitty job strategy.
You see what I'm going?
- Yeah.
- Be smart with the shitty job.
- Right now, I just recently
got hired on to Goodwill.
But cause the Krone, I only
worked there for one day
and I'm quarantined and
I'm on unpaid furlough so--
- That's amazing, you got lucky bro.
You snuck that in.
- I got fucking lucky
Oh my God
I'm lucky right now.
- On the business on a job
front, you fucking gratitude
the fuck out of that.
- Honestly, I feel so
fucking lucky because
I'm grateful that I, my rent,
I pay only $400 for rent.
I have amazing landlord.
He forgave my rent for
this month because of
what the hell is going
on and all this shit.
We have a really great relationship
and I'm just so grateful
I've been through so much
shit and I'm just so happy
that I'm at a good spot
where I can actually start
the life that I want to be.
- The person I wanna be.
- You gonna be.
You already did the hardest part.
Running ways impossible.
That's a mental battle,
it's easy to pack your shit
and walk out the door, that
mental warfare is incredible
you have so much strength.
- Thank you.
- I admire you so much.
- Thank you , man.
- You're welcome.
Now if you sell that Jordan
hat on Facebook marketplace
for 26 (mumbles) I'll have even more.
- I was talking to my landlord,
its funny cause I also did
some Thrift Store stuff too.
I remember going down to go down to Irvine
or another Goodwill before
I worked at Goodwill,
and I bought a...
Dude this was the craziest story.
I bought a Rocket Raccoon,
I got it for two bucks
at a Goodwill.
- A stuffed animal one?
- Stuffed animal Rocket Raccoon.
I sold that shit for 30 bucks because
they were selling
hotcakes for $32 on eBay.
- Alex, I gave you the
shitty job strategy,
the greatest strategy in my opinion,
is Goodwill garage sales
flea markets flip life.
I can't explain enough to
people that make minim wage,
how they'll make more money
and have more fun doing
the flip life.
- I think the hardest
part for me it's my car,
cause my car has a sentimental value.
- Bro, have humility.
Get on the bus and go to Goodwill
and then get on the bus again.
When my mom came to this
country, we use to walk...
Mom how far was fucking
Kmart for the house?
She's in her headphones, here she comes.
(mumbles) delay, watch this,
I'm gonna wait for my mom
she's watching over in the corner.
Mom, how far do we walk to
Kmart, when we came to America?
- That's close probably five miles.
- We used to walk five fucking
miles to Kmart and back.
- Damn!
- Because there was no fucking choice.
Cause we didn't have a car,
because my mom needed...
And by the way, I was fucking
lazy, I didn't that walk,
I used to jump with my mom shoulders.
She had to drag my ass, my
little sister was younger,
she was cool but, I couldn't do it.
- I used to take the bus too.
- Five miles bro
, why can't you?
Of course, it sounds crazy but
when your timing work shift
when your alternative is
getting a seven, 12, nine bucks,
how much you getting paid a Goodwill?
Break it down for me.
- $13 at Goodwill.
- When you're fucking
getting paid $13 pre,
all the shit that comes out of it,
your time is not worth that much.
All the sudden walking two
hours doesn't seem so crazy.
And definitely taking a
bus doesn't seem crazy.
- Yeah, I've taken the bus before, I--
- What else doesn't sound crazy?
Making a social media post saying,
"Yo does anybody have a car that's willing
"to drive me around,
I'll pay for your gas,
"and I'll give you 5% of what I sell."
Oh, now we've got that flip the switch,
people always got an excuse
I've always got a fucking answer.
The answer is humility and creativity.
- Gotcha.
- Or you make a trade.
Anybody out there got a
shitty job that with a car,
I'll teach you the flip
life, you drive me around,
you see where I'm going,
now you got a friend,
it's fucking offense,
optimism, humility, creativity,
these are the fucking games.
- I think I need to be more optimistic
about my life then.
- The reason I using
acronyms, I'm gonna call it
the choo-choo theory.
Creativity, humility, optimism, offense.
choo-choo motherfucker.
- Definitely.
I agree with that.
So, I'll do my very best to look at it--
- Get on that train Alex.
I love you, brother.
- Thank you, appreciate Gary
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- I'm killing it with the acronyms.
Give me something for that one Dustin.
That was on the fly quick.
I know you fucking love
that choo-choo theory, bro.
I could see the Instagram
post already with the default
fucking train emoji, I fucking got
this choo-choo motherfucker.
People can do this bro.
Thank you all for watching so much.
The All-In Challenge,
I've got a crazy offer
on The All-In Challenge,
$10 raffle tickets you buy
a 20 pack for 100 bucks so
it's five $5 raffle tickets,
and I'm giving away something crazy,
I'm giving away this.
I am giving away the
ultimate GaryVee experience.
How should I go, okay.
Over the last week or so I've
been jamming with my friend
Michael Rubin and helping out
on this All-In Challenge that
I am accepting right now,
but allinchallenge.comm, please go there,
we're challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes
in the world to provide
a ridiculous all time experience,
or one of their most iconic
items in their collection
to help raise money to
help feed the hungry,
during this ridiculous time.
And so now I have to put up my auction.
So my auction, the
ultimate GaryVee experience
here we go, I'm gonna go
off the top of the head.
I did go on allinchallenge.com
to go bid on this.
I am giving away...
You get to, in the course of the year,
you will go garage sailing
with me, and film "Trash Talk".
Also you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti,
so I know a lot of you
pay attention to that part
of my world.
Also, we're gonna go to Wine Library
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right.
I'm gonna pay my dad, 25,000.
So $5,000 shopping spree at Wine Library,
I will walk through the whole store
with you tell you the war stories,
and you will buy a bunch
of wine, beer, liquor
whatever you want, food.
We are gonna go to a Jets game together,
you're gonna tailgate with me.
I never do this when I give
away Jets tickets I never let
the person sit with me so
you will sit with me during
the Jets game.
I won't talk to you during the game,
I'm completely focused
but you'll get that so
the ultimate Jets experienced
tailgate full game
with me as well.
Also I'm gonna give you one
week, play at VaynerMedia,
so this is for you and
a plus one, by the way,
so the two tickets,
we'll do some plus ones,
we'll do some just me and
you depending on what it is.
One full week at VaynerMedia
getting consulting
and business advice
from Teen GaryVee and me
for the entire week
hanging out in the pit,
where the show's done.
You gonna be a guest of my podcast,
we're gonna do a wine dinner for you,
and seven of your friends
at Hint & Fish Club
in New York City, and I'm gonna
fly you, all paid, plus one
to three of my keynotes, and
we'll work on those details.
The ultimate GaryVee experience.
I hope you bid on it, I
hope you get involved.
I hope we raise a lot
of money to help people
that need it.
Also what's so fun about
the All-IN Challenge is,
you get to challenge people to be in it.
I'm gonna challenge all
the VaynerSports athletes,
I expect you in there
so that is number one.
Number two, I'm gonna
go with, oh, Timbaland,
the super producer, who's
completely lighting up Instagram.
Timbaland the super producer
I'm calling you out.
And finally...
I got one, The Undertaker,
one of the great wrestlers
of all time.
Please join the challenge.
Everybody go to allinchallenge.com.
Please support this, the
experiences are gonna be nuts.
We've been working-bleeding
out of the eyeballs,
for the last week putting
this all together,
you gonna be blown away
what you're about to see
on social media, #allinchallenge.
Please check it out and
please go to your favorite
celebrities, athletes and entertainers,
and leave #allinchallenge
to get them involved.
The All-In Challenge, please take it.